the main focus of today's council was
the exchange of views on the European
semester documents in particular
employment and social policy aspects of
the country specific recommendations
after active discussions an agreement
has been reached on this issue council
conclusions were supported on equal
income opportunities for women and men
closing the gender gap during the
meeting the council conclusions on the
implementation of the youth guarantee
were also adopted the Commission stands
ready to assist member states in
reforming their economies yesterday's a
European Commission's college decided to
set up a new service structural reform
support service and any member state not
only program countries will be able to
request technical assistance to help
them in the implementation of
growth-enhancing administrative and
structural reforms although and even
across the European Union the
implementation of the youth guarantee is
bearing fruit however for its more
successful implementation increased
efforts are needed on outreach in
particular to the most marginalized
young people the council agreed on a
general approach on medical devices and
on vitro diagnostic medical devices the
aim is to ensure patient safety quality
control and availability of innovations